the Arctic's 2080 and archaic 2080 TI
are really powerful cards but even they
are struggling to get really good FPS
with retracing enabled and with great
crazy technology already only been
supported by a handful of games the
archives 2080 in 2080 I don't really
make that much sense
[Music]
welcome to Haris hobbies so first let's
take a look at the performance without
ray-tracing enabled so starting off the
r-tx 2080 TI is on average 23% faster
than the gtx 980ti
at 1440p at 4k the Arctic's 2080 TI is
on average 30% faster than the GTX 22 TI
so as you guys can see there's a pretty
good generational gap between a
flagships of the two series but the
story changes with the RT x 2080 and
1440p the RT x 2080 is only about 1%
faster than the gtx 980ti
and the same story continues with 4k the
art takes 2080 is only about 1% faster
overall the Arctic's 2080 and GT x 1080
TI are pretty much identical cards now
you may be wondering why i'm comparing
these two cards not the GTX 280 in r2
2080 well here's the thing the arch of
2080 is still more expensive than GT x
1080 Ti so only people who are concerned
to get the GT 1080i are going to
consider the Arctic's 2080 so it makes
more sense to compare those two than the
GTX 1080 and r-tx 2080 so as far as
traditional gaming performance goes the
Arctic's 2080 Ti is a pretty good solid
improvement over last generation however
the RT x 2080 is really quite pointless
even there it is over $200 more than the
gtx 980ti and yet it provides an
unprecedented ifferent and the Arctic's
2080 Ti is really not that much better
please follow the performance upgrade as
around 30% over the gtx 980ti
that price almost double at over $1,200
now wait
forgetting something all right the r-tx
2080 and 2080 I have rate tracing
technology while the GTX 1080i it does
not but here's the issue with that so
here's what you can expect with the r-tx
20 80 TI with the brain tracing enabled
for battlefield 5 at AAP you can expect
to get around 60 frames per second at
1440p you can expect to get 40 to 50
frames per second and if we're running
at 4k it's getting me less than 30
frames per second moving on to Metro
Exodus right now with the RK 28 TI @ KP
you can expect to get around 40 frames
per second the developers are hoping to
get that to 60 frames per second in the
imminent future and with shadow of the
Tomb Raider the same issue persists the
RT x 28 e TI struggles to even reach 60
frames per second at 1080 P right now is
fluctuating in 30s and 40s
so overall right now ray tracing is only
moderately playable for 1080p and for
1440p and 4k it is completely pointless
and that is just for the art GX 28 e TI
so imagine how bad it will be for the
art GX 2080
so overall right now raytrace technology
is pretty much completely unusable
because of the utterly low frame rates
furthermore most games were won even
support this technology in the first
place so in the end while great razor
technology is a really cool piece of
tech right now it really is just
worthless gold so here are my thoughts
for the two cards
as for the RTS 2080 as far as
ray-tracing goes it is pretty much
pointless but his ray tracing is already
struggling to uneven on the r-tx 2080 TI
and asked for traditional gearing
performance the RTS 2080 is pretty much
identical with the gtx 980ti
so you might as well just save some
money and go with the gtx 1080i instead
the only reason that I would even
consider the RG x 2080
as if it drops to $700 and the price
difference between the gtx 980ti
and RTS 2080 is less than $100 but
then it is just as on novelty I wouldn't
actually use for a tracing on a
consistent basis so make sure to keep
that in mind ask for the r-tx 28 ET i
again great racing technology is
completely pointless because it's only
just playable at 1080p and anybody who
can afford the r-tx 2080 Ti is not going
to be gaming at 1080p and for the few
souls who are gave me a 1080p Anna can
afford the Arc'teryx 180 I just please
don't buy this card instead just go out
and buy a gtx 980ti and grab a brand new
4k monitor but that will probably be
cheaper and the resolution increase that
you will see would be a lot better than
whatever you will get out of ray tracing
I think the art is 2080 TI is a solid
upgrade and traditional gaming
performance but I really don't think
it's justified by its price the only
reason you should consider our t20 atti
is if you already have a max gaming
setup with everything already maxed out
and you have a lot of money to burn and
you have absolutely no other way to
spend it and you already bought an
iPhone 10x max you've already been down
that road and you're right now you're
just stuck and yes the RT X 28 di is the
perfect card for you and you will
definitely enjoy the 30 frames per
second extra that you will be getting
but all jokes aside both of these cards
are really quite pointless right now and
ray-tracing technology just isn't there
yet so just go ahead and get a GTA 1080
or 1080 TI plays they're really both
great cards and will last you for a very
very long time in the future but that's
pretty much all I have for you guys this
time so what do you guys think do you
guys think these cards are worth it also
do you think Nvidia will launch these
seems cards but without the rate rated
technology for example a GTX 2080 and
the GTX 2080 ti-84 $607 for the GTX 2080
and 700 to 800 for the GTX 20 DTI cuz
then these cards will make a lot more
sense make sure to comment down below
what you guys think because I do read
all my comments I'm curious as to what
you guys think so make sure to post your
thoughts also if you guys like feel they
make sure drop a like and consider
subscribing if you want to see more
videos just like this
but until then I'm hearty I'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]